video games are an interactive
experience but that doesn't always mean
we play them the right way I think we
can all collectively agree that uh we do
some dumb video games whether that's
abiding traffic laws and grand theft
auto or training a game of Street
Fighter into Chow sting this is the dumb
[ __ ] we do in video games when I was
younger I had this one friend that was
always in competition with and it was
for literally everything
who could wake up the earliest who could
walk to school the fastest who could get
to lunch the quickest who could read a
book in a day who could read the most
books in a day who could read the most
best books in a day Mornington that
competition it was a ridiculous time and
we both loved video games which
naturally meant we competed at video
games and we both loved street fighter
so we played a lot of three fire and
needed to figure out who was better or
the two of us now Street Fighter is a
game that's created to decide who's
better out of two people you just play
the game versus the winner is better but
for some reason we thought that wasn't
good enough for us and instead we were
gonna come up with our own way of
deciding who was better and that way was
something called Street Fighter 2
jousting
I don't know how we came up with these
rules but effectively we'd both pick a
character Peters picker you I'd pick n
because Ken's better red kicks flames
awesome and then we go into the match
round one fight there would be a
countdown three two one and then we'd
both back up not to the edge of the
screen because otherwise the moves that
you use to joust wouldn't work but just
far enough to be a safe distance
distance away travel distance and then
there'd be another countdown three two
one go an on goal with both input the
command for the hurricane kick the
tatsumaki senpukyaku which is a course i
go back and kick if you know three fire
you know what happens they both travel
across the screen with a leg spinning
around and first foot that connects does
the damage sometimes both feet connect
at the same time and they both do damage
and we did that for hours best of 50 and
I think the reasoning was three fighters
inputs were not difficult pipe modern
standards but back in the day as kids
using controllers that would slice up
your fingers it was tricky so if you
could consistently input a command you
clearly the better of the two player so
if you fail to empower command you a
week
[Music]
and it was a monumental waste of time
like bad use of a life a child's life
even as a kid I probably knew that but
couldn't face it
and the other stupid thing was like it
usually end up in a drawer we just
forget because we'd lose track of it
because we're trying to do first of 50
and there'd be double chaos in there
we'd get into arguments about of that we
were stupid kids and we did a lot of
dumb stuff while playing video games and
this was one of them when I was a kid
maybe eight or nine years old we had a
copy of the Sims on our computer and I
had a character and my sister had a
character and my brother did as well as
our next-door neighbor's at the time who
were roughly the same age as us and I
had a pretty big crush on my neighbor
let's call her Sarah so instead of
telling Sarah how I felt about her in
real life I figured the best way to go
about it would be to have our Sims marry
each other so for the next couple of
weeks I would invite Sarah sim over to
my house and I'd make her dinner and we
watched TV she'd leave her plate
half-finished on the floor sometimes and
walk away but you know whatever it was
all progress but for some reason when I
talked to her I could never move past
hugging that was basically the peak of
my Sims affection towards her and I
wanted to kiss her and eventually
propose but I couldn't do it and I asked
my sister what the problem was and she
told me to bring up how I had allocated
my sim skill points my personality
points and we realized that I hadn't put
any points into outgoing because I
didn't know what it meant at the time
because I was 8 years old and my sister
told me that my sim would never be able
to propose or kiss because he wasn't
brave enough to make make a move and
push things past hugs so yeah I died we
never we never consummated that the Sims
never consummated the marriage I'd like
to think that somewhere on a computer
hard drive rotting and rusting in the
landfill my sim is still calling over
Sarah sim to this day watching patiently
as she eats her meal waiting for the day
to come when she realized the true
love's been sitting there all along
talking your ear off about sunglasses or
pizza ah to be young and know loved but
not yet know what outgoing means when it
comes to dumb she's done in games it's
kind of hard
to narrow it down to just one but I
think my favorite has to be and it goes
for any grand theft auto game but I'm
gonna start by saying by city as my
favorites but in grand theft auto
there's just something about abiding all
the traffic laws and driving like an
actual ball abiding citizen it's super
weird and super dumb but I've always
enjoyed doing that in GT for some reason
you know you roll up next to a cop and
you're like yeah I'm a criminal but you
don't even know because look how perfect
my driving is and it's super silly and
super crazy but vice city also had in my
opinion the best soundtrack of all GTA
games it was nice to just cruise you
know chill out listen to the music and
all the cars were super dope in that
game too so it was a perfect storm for
the dumbest [ __ ] now hold on before we
go into this final segment I just need
to say that this is not dumb in fact
it's disgustingly adorable and if you
think otherwise you need to get in touch
with your feelings
one of the amazing things about being
stuck at home these past few weeks is my
kids finding Zelda breath of the wild
it's a game that they took to in really
unexpected ways I'm a mama chicken I
have one daughter who likes to take care
of chickens she named each one she
stalks them like she's their mama ocean
water this is a plane when arranged she
takes them inside one at a time she'll
also spend hours just running up a hill
over and over again and gliding off or
tossing them all in the roof of her
chicken coop hearing chickens squawk for
hours at a time it can be pretty
maddening
but fortunately I've invested in
noise-canceling headphones we're not
doing that cheese up at goron hot
springs setting her underwear on fire Oh
relax about I'm gonna say no fire and
then jumping in the pools which
fortunately put out the fire and give
you your health back meanwhile my other
daughter really likes horses like quite
a lot
oh when you've got your horses they
actually tell you if they're gentle
thumper are only on gently temper one
and it's glitter force - she's all her
work temperance is wild tempered she
gets up early every morning and feeds
them takes him for walks make sure that
their exercise she does an agility
course on a hillside and generally keeps
her horses happy and fit
she's also filled the entire inventory
with dishes she's cooked every time you
make up just food it actually is a
really gross um what it does is um right
like it just doesn't like black stuff
all around it and it like makes a
farting noise my kids do really really
silly things and it keeps them
entertained for hours and that is only a
glimpse of some of the ungainly things
we do in the games we love but it
doesn't stop there I know you do dumb
don't lie to me
I know you do and I want to see it so if
you'd like send it my way on twitter at
curt underscore in Davina and or you can
just jump in the comments and leave your
own story I know I for one don't want to
admit how many baguettes
I've shoved down the mailing to the Grim
Fandango just simply because I can't
also if you're itching for more of this
there's actually an article you can
check out the description below of all
the other dumps we hear GameSpot do in
video games anyways that's it thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]